in eSports a great play can stand on its
own but it doesn't become truly iconic
it doesn't become ingrained in the
hearts and minds of fans without great
commentary attached to it
I'm column for the score eSports and
previously we've given you the top ten
caster calls in DotA League of Legends
csgo and fighting games and now well
it's time to give you the top ten
casters in eSports period these are the
broadcast talents who give us goosebumps
these are the guys whose commentary is
attached to the most iconic plays from
their eSport these people are a big part
of the reason we love eSports baseball
shall be rewarded
zeppelins various what is that because
that simple
now before we get started guys remember
this is our list of the top ten casters
in eSports it's not an exact science
yours might and probably will look a
little different so sit back get ready
to post your own list in the comment
section which is here are the top 10
casters in all of eSports the first spot
on our list goes to the best-dressed
caster in all of eSports Agust Semler
Masson app you've most likely heard his
voice gracing the broadcast of the
overwatch league
watch me
but between 2013 and 2017
Semler became a legend casting
counter-strike alongside longtime duo
partner Anders who spoiler alert we will
be talking about later in this list
Semler rose to the pinnacle of csgo
casting more than 40 premiere events and
more than a few major finals shot into
the 1v1 we go in so little time no way
is he gonna get it in the nick of time
but whether it's overwatch or CS go or
any other game the level of
professionalism and dedication he brings
to the craft marks him as one of the
great ones when it comes to broadcast
talent shot C is God the ACE still alive
as well peaking buying as much time as
you can hoping that a teammate will be
able to support him for help
for his team side and well that's what
happens when you go around the corner
happy with one day
the phrase like sweating bullets
the number nine spot on our list belongs
to Sam Coby Hartman Ken's ler while the
entire NA and honestly EU broadcast team
is full a fantastic talent we couldn't
have this list just beat NLCS casters
Coby has been involved with League of
Legends from the very beginning
joining Riot as a caster for the
inaugural na LCS season he's cast every
split since as well as every midseason
Invitational and every worlds event in
the LCS era
God's impact on the way of the same
today +1 Simba's so does impact he's
gonna
if you've ever watched League you very
likely heard Kobe's voice over some of
the game's most iconic moments Kobe's
passion for the game shines through in
his analysis as well as his hypest
moments our number 8 spot belongs to
David LD Gorman the co-founder of beyond
the summit brought the eastern dota
tournaments like gee League and G est
2012 to English audiences his work
casting these s EA events for the
Western world exploded his popularity
and he was invited to ti2 and the ball
hasn't stopped rolling since LD has cast
every TI since 2012 more than 15 other
premier tournaments and through BTS has
supported many of the smaller community
events throughout the dota scene as far
as his casting goes his voice is
attached to a moment known throughout
the DOTA community simply as the play
Ancients from so waiting the wave now
he's about to be caught oh there's to
sleep but sorry he catches everyone oh
this could be a total disaster
every would the black balls well-managed
turns it around
Danny
that's why I'm trying to survive [ __ ]
gonna come down in the past five years l
DS voice has covered some incredible
dota moments and for that you certainly
earned a spot on our list
what is the road waiting for the jump in
war cry coming down to the pod
angels instead nine
they're gonna do it that panes of an
online quiz gee I
the Alliance just won one point four
million dollars they are your
international grand champion the faces
of faceit james Bardolph and daniel DDK
Kapadia come in at the number seven spot
on this list this csgo casting duo came
together in 2014 her face at league
season two and quickly Daniel and James
became fan favorites and it's not hard
to see or hear why
[Applause]
stupid walk around link outside with
Lyle
[Applause]
call the number they came back all the
way double spokes in the same plane
sensible
what is that this is not FBI this is a
pager a simple into this us in this guy
is absolutely unbelievable he's the
x-factor / team Lee good there is no
question I have no words I have no words
there's simple I don't know man if he
comes in with this mouth that he had one
button there was no Zune
here he comes once again the first base
is the trainees gonna hit the ground
there's cold safely velocity with your
play thinkable seeds there on the B
apartments they need a huge play but
that was something I'm never gonna see
ever again ridiculous stuff more than
simply casting the action in a round of
Bardolph and DDK bring a level of
wordplay of hype and of passion that has
catapulted them to the top of the
casting pecking order in counter-strike
they want the mayonnaise in their
burgers and the mustards and all the
trimmings they don't just won the bun
they want all the lettuce the tomatoes
down the garlic the roasted onions let's
go hello make some noise
got enough noise I like to make some
noise in this batch
that makes some noise
[Applause]
a great caster has the power to pull on
our heartstrings to remind us why we
love the games we love and few do a
better job of that than the number six
entry on our list fighting game caster
James chin often hurt alongside casting
partner Ultra David Chen has been a
constant voice in the fgc for about a
decade now with that experience comes a
nearly unrivaled knowledge of fighting
games and after all these years in the
business after the unendingly long days
casting pools or writing community
guides after all the weekend spent
locked up in hotel convention centers
James Chen's passion for fighting games
has only grown by a man's are great you
guys don't know that's what got James
the workers it almost got me too I won't
lie it would it wouldn't be evil without
that view would it
[Applause]
there's no other better way to say it
fighting games are great the fact that
they bring all these people together to
play for one hobby like this at an event
like this thousands of people speaking
just like the universal language of the
fighting game as a pillar of the fgc
Chen's emotion his knowledge and his
dedication it Pitta mises what it means
to be a great eSports caster this is
what video games do they you Knight us
they bring us together they bring people
from all sorts of different communities
together to enjoy something that we all
he's got all that screen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
peanut butter in jail bacon and eggs
SATA kissed and Henry G rounding out the
top five is a duo we just couldn't bring
ourselves to separate csgo broadcasters
Matt say to kiss trivet and Henry Henry
G career while Sato provides the
lightning-fast wordplay humor and
play-by-play calls
that'll have you on the edge of your
seat first by specifics already put it
back down KGB's gonna go forward stance
all for them working the other one goes
the inside the trimming out they cruise
back out of the one top that I'm not
sure who it is but it's to be just the
twelve ease P to work with he has got
the butterfly knife but he has to fly
like I shouldn't butterfly and sting
like a bee he's not the first one
already on the Kerrigan house fall away
further still in the box his lower
device he's got this down one on one he
actually works it out the clutter exists
I love it Henry brings the kind of
gravitas to the action that makes you
feel the entire world is resting on
whatever play he's casting there we go
that is Niko coming in the fact I states
that Chris J all of a sudden is whipped
around once again two versus one the
world's best player up against it to
stay in the game they'll go crazy
together these two casters have produced
more than their share of legendary sound
bites that remain unforgettable for csgo
fans everywhere suddenly the last alive
this is a dud round Guardian Maoist
question as to whether he'll save the
AWP good flashbang could get a couple
more out of this one
I starting to crumble what's going on
one player has found three kills
Guardian looking to Ace this one now
this could be one of the best rounds of
the entire tournament so far four kills
picked up his down the krims this was a
five versus one map and Cindy Airy could
be a factor because if he puts it in
front of Guardian how does he work back
in it's gone toward the dumpster that
means guardian knows exactly where there
is the world's best diaper comes to life
in the fibre versus one just snacks does
find one on let's not leave him out of
this the Big Apple and snacks is hungry
he's got one kill already of the USP low
HP as well on Guardian and flame he's
trying to beat them out trying to get
them into a wall on long as he dances
back and forth between the
[Applause]
what
sick-ass baseball cards I've ever seen
and the entirety of csgo the number four
spot on our list belongs to a duo
affectionately known as the rain bros
Christopher Montecristo michaelis and
Eric Doyle um Quist
coming from Warcraft 3 and Starcraft 2
respectively both Monti and Doha have a
rich history in eSports but the duo is
perhaps best known for being the former
English voices of Korean League of
Legends this group of players that have
either retired or been rejected by other
teams comes in no big sponsor no big
team house it's not necessary because
they are going to win
lck summer and they are going to get a
spotted world to get there it is brunch
Tigers taken GG it's about time and that
is its curtain is in charge
first first place is bears graduation
from the latter half of 2012 to 2016
they were able to balance the
jaw-dropping action with the slow and
intellectual macro play the lck region
is known for good with a you I lay the
qss I can't start a song actually in
2016 they made the jump to overwatch
casting apex the overwatch World Cup and
most recently the inaugural season of
the overwatch
will sue that start to take quickly
there it goes New York Excelsior both
times bring up no matter the game we can
always count on Monty in Doha to bring
the hype
is that just jtro it's gonna take it
right here max this is going down all
they need to do is [ __ ] sit oh my god
I died yet
and the laughs hey guys welcome to lck
summer on OGN your home for great teams
dank memes and crushed na dreams it's
absolute brush shine saw bliss come in
they come all todd the cuvette style oh
that was one of the saddest things even
if you don't know dota chances are you
know the number three spot on our list
Toby Toby Wan Dawson he's cast every
international and more than 30 premiere
events in DotA 2 alone with forays into
Call of Duty csgo and even pub G with
his golden pipes it's a new dawn
it's a new day
some new life
it's a disaster he's become the voice of
dota 2 with someone as beloved as toby
is there's always more to say but in
this case we'll let the legend himself
do the talking
thief in the night
put it down but only take the engines
need water
VP TP heart they need that Angus they
needed that for the fight that blaster
they're all together PPT he comes the
eyes flash ready
[Applause]
you know runner-up spot is the man who
perhaps comes the closest to earning the
title the voice of counter-strike Anders
Blum it's hard to think about
professional csgo and not hear his voice
the voice that has graced so many of the
game's most iconic moments since the
start of 2013 they're gonna try and go
for here they want to go all in Eco
comes in with another kill him back to a
two-on-two that foams so far take they
gotta move quick right now it was
Andrews passion for csgo shines through
in every game he's ever provided the
soundtrack for whether it's casting with
his longtime partner Semler
or more recently alongside fellow cs
broadcasting talent Jason Moses O'Toole
just a few seconds left es seven six
legs Fryeburg goes for the kill he's
gonna pick it up if just existence of
eyes he's gonna win there's no time for
a way to equalize the situation he's
gonna be walking up spots pronax here in
the corner takes him down turns around
for the 180 still 15 five years on his
passion his dedication and his ability
to give us goosebumps hasn't diminished
one bit in a one versus three and
luminosity they are one round away from
match and map point here kenny in a
single headshot he's got the double
sprays gets one more there's no goddamn
way that he's gonna do this he's got no
health cold gonna go break at shot
Johnny or joy
oh my god but it is too late
Garen is gonna be waiting he co charges
in doesn't check quads reactions he Co
not even with an aimbot could you have
got that you have you take the most
complex the most nuanced and sometimes
the slowest eSport on the planet and
make it something truly drilling well
you just call taste ptosis I didn't know
Protoss players are so famous Wow
because they have a lot of stalkers
taking our top spot is a casting duo
that has been around since the dawn of
eSports time Dan artosis stemkowski and
Nicolas tasteless plot the casting our
car is coming forward he's taking the
Ravagers out be honest
countered they all in but wait there's
some more links coming in here now he
does like out of that half of him that's
gonna
my god tastes OSIS as the duo are
commonly known were some of the first
Westerners on Korean soil broadcasting
eSports boom for the rest of the world
hey what's up guys this is tasteless I'm
down here in Seoul Korea as many of you
may know filming me right now is artosis
there is right now their chemistry the
humor they infused into every broadcast
has made them the most endearing casting
duo in all of eSports
are you serious 150 families 25 more on
the way I think this might be the most
babe lakes in GSL history it might be is
so so so so so many paintings oh look a
roll roll rolling through everything
tasteless they're going to kill every
season every planetary Terran is not
saved but it's the siege tanks whatever
if you're not convinced yet these guys
are so beloved they made it into their
own game your allies base is under
attack time to carry ok on the count of
2 late started thespian guys are
exhausted
[Music]
you need more depots sorry this is a
hard game these are the casters casters
I don't care if you've never watched a
minute of Starcraft in your life simply
put there is no other broadcast duo in
the world that make you feel as electric
and at the same time as at ease as taste
dosis does even on the grandest stage of
them all job stay that upward rage he's
hiding too well
all this fighting all the babies is so
good
Splash Damage is gone he's led in the
Vikings there's two
yes guitar
forward and I think I saw us well lose
this game
my god what happens when you experience
a rush on the ladder when I go on the
ladder get my nerd gun out like this
point
give me a guy that ladder points no one
leaves here alive I've never felt so
alive
that's right now stay alive I did it the
time he was purple right now
well guys that's our list and I got to
tell you it was nearly impossible to
produce we had to cut a lot of
incredible casters and commentators and
it hurt my soul just a little bit to do
so what I want you to do though is post
your own top ten list of the best
eSports casters in the comment section
and I will see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]